andrew tate they've removed him i don't
know what's what why they're removing
him
they're just removing people now they
don't like it seems
yeah and they never give a clear cut
here they never give a reason i mean by
the way i've heard a lot of what he has
said and i know some of it gets people
going but i you know some of what he
says that i've heard
isn't that crazy
what is this misogyny is a hateful
ideology that is not tolerated on tick
tock
what that's not true
um
yeah i just they seem like they're
removing
people with whom
they have
underlying ideological differences
and they're just trying to figure out
how to get rid of them
and again
i'm not
joining hustlers university i won't be
signing up
but i don't think you should this guy
should be uh removed
i i don't you
know what is like do they even tell
anyone why
well they just say you're misogynist but
then they don't like the the thing is
they don't link you to the specific
thing
but wasn't even misogynist a month ago
when he was on too like this is what i
don't understand why
what's changed
why can't a misogynist talk
i don't understand
he thinks let's say he thinks men are
better than women
let's say he has that belief
i mean i don't know it can should he not
be able to say anything
you know
i i i'm just
i'm
unmoved
people will counter his belief with
their own beliefs
some of them will be quite persuasive
you know
i just don't understand
why now it's like misogyny
is it grounds yeah and now we're getting
kicked off and apparently he's been
booted from twitter as of 2017 because
he tweeted now here's a specific one
right he tweeted that women who are
sexually assaulted bear some
responsibility
i don't know the context of that post
but or what made him think it but
i think if you look at his larger quote
his larger context
he said something to the extent that if
you go out and get drunk and go home
with a guy and get into his bed and he
does the wrong thing
you have to analyze some of your
behavior now by the way you could be
offended by that it's absolutely
appropriate to be offended by that and
say i i think that he's
or excusing uh
rape
but
i also don't think by the way
that that is a crazy beyond the pale
opinion that is not held by lots of
people and what i mean by that is this
there are a lot of reasonable rational
people out there that think that yes men
are violent
certainly when you add alcohol to the
mix and they're strangers and it doesn't
justify their behavior at all
but the idea that a woman doesn't have
to take extra care to protect herself
in our society is probably
naive to believe that
so i don't
you know i i i again i just think that
like
they want a villain
and he may want to be the villain i
don't know i think they're casting him
in the role as the villain and maybe he
wants to be that role
i don't know him but if if i look at the
the
examples i'm being given here
i'm not seeing anything sufficient to
remove this guy
from social media yeah completely
i don't see any reason for that
and again no one's gonna care what i say
right
but i did just
speak on the joe rogan show and i said
the most um
i said the most meaningful thing that's
ever been said
on his show uh that that rant i had was
the most
articulate meaningful thing that's ever
been said in the history of the world
to be honest it was
do you believe there was anything that's
ever been said that's better than that
uh
sermon on the mount
what's the sermon on the map i think
it's uh
it's that one jesus did where he was
like
we should all like be nice to each other
and stuff yeah how'd that work out like
i'm like
like it's like i'm talking about [ __ ]
that's real
it's gonna actually happen
you're talking about fairy tales
um
yeah i just listen
i'm not saying that women are should be
blamed for rape i'm saying that
someone should be allowed to offer an
opinion on a controversial
situation
he's in one video he demonstrates how he
would attack a female partner if she
ever accused him of cheating
quote it's bang out the machete boom in
her face and grip her by the neck shut
up [ __ ]
um
it's bang out the machete boom in the
face and grip her by the neck shut up
[ __ ]
um what's he doing there cutting her
head off
uh he's just describing uh how he would
attack a female partner if she ever uh
accused him of cheating and he goes it's
bang out the machete boom in her face
and grip her by the neck like you got to
threaten her she got it right up next to
her well but if my whole thing is if he
didn't cheat
and she's accusing her cheating how's he
supposed to respond
i'm
i'm confused
um
maybe it's in maybe it's in a better
context here should we play this maybe
it'll make sense yes
okay
a man can only cheat if he loves someone
else if i have a woman who i truly love
and i go out and [ __ ] and i come back to
her and i don't care about her and i
only love my girl that's not cheating
that's exercise
if she even talks to her it's very funny
by the way that's incredibly funny yeah
it's not that bad
well
well you know listen man
people are gonna this is what's gonna
happen
um
the bigger you get the more of a target
you become and listen i'm not saying
andrew tate is
you know i don't think he should be
the go-to for i think young guys
listening to him probably
will get some bad ideas in their head
but this young people often have bad
ideas in their head and good ideas in
their head and they sort them out as
they get older this is not new
none of this is new i had bad ideas in
my head when i grew up and you know who
they were from my parents
you know now there's people on the
internet that can influence people for
sure
but there's a lot of other people that
can influence you too positively
negatively
i don't see any rule the ruling is
gavel put him back on social media
please i don't see any reason
holding a machete to someone's neck if
that's a problem well i don't know get
me out of here
you didn't do it he said it
yeah i'll put a machete to someone's i
mean that's hypothetically speaking he
would do such a thing if he said if
right
x then why
if i'm accused of cheating i'll use the
machete
but he's not really gonna do it it's
probably a goof
it's a joke i don't know
there's there's got to be a villain all
the time
we're a society and you make a lot of
money being the villain by the way
people like villainizing you
and um
around time the uk police were
investigating abused hate is understood
to have left you came from romania and
one video explaining his reasons for the
movie suggested it was because it'd be
easier to evade rape charges
he goes this is quote for probably 40 of
the reason
i'm not a rapist but i like the idea of
just being able to do what i want i like
being free
well but does that mean he's raping
people
technically no
he's saying he likes the idea of having
it as an option because you could read
that two ways he goes listen i'm not a
rapist i like the idea of being able to
do what i want i like the idea
of doing that when i'm free so i think
there's a way to interpret that where
he's going listen i'm not like so sicko
i just don't want to be uh i don't want
to live in a nanny state
but i didn't know
you know what i mean like i think he's
then in april the brothers mansion was
raided by police following a tip-off
from the us embassy that a 20-year-old
21-year-old american woman was being
held against her will
tates were taken in for questioning
before being released and denying
wrongdoing the romanian authorities said
last week that the investigation
later expanded to cover human
trafficking and rape allegations was
ongoing
yeah i mean
i don't know about any of this he just
had a cam house where he would like
there was like cam girls and stuff
i mean what are you gonna do
i mean you know
my problem is when you take somebody off
social media they can't respond to any
of this right this is the big problem if
you destroy people's ability to respond
you can say stuff about them
and this is a gavin mcginnis point
actually that i'm making here
many years ago when i when i knew gavin
um who
he is also controversial
um
but
gavin
said yeah they kicked me off all these
things and i couldn't respond so people
could say anything about me they could
say i'm a nazi i'm this i'm not
and i did not have any
place to respond to what was being said
about me
so no matter what you think about gavin
that that is a
valid
argument that if you kick somebody off
and you call them names
maybe they're true maybe they're not but
that person now has no recourse
to talk back
and then you can kind of villainize them
[Music]
and create this character that they may
or may not have been
and this seems to be
the mo of a lot of these companies this
is what it seems to be it does not seem
to be
changing
and i do believe this ultimately
will lead to a
kind of a
schism
google schism and tell everyone what it
means
this is going to lead to a schism
it is a split or decision between
strongly opposed sections or parties
caused by differences in opinion or
beliefs that's correct but this is what
it means
what it means is that
i believe you're going to see i think
rumbles one of the first
attempts at this with a lot of
people on it you're going to just
further see
uh people
retreating into
their corners here you think you think
tate will go to rumble
i could he could be a rumble guy i could
see that yeah oh yeah for sure or uh
as a pickup artist guy those guys
usually have their own websites he could
go on like a pickup artist for him and
and probably destroy behind his own
paywall though right listen
i don't know what he's doing i'm sure
the courses he teaches are not
uh
going to lead you to be a billionaire
but i think when you just take somebody
off all of social media
uh it is you know there has to be some
there has to be
andrew tate's hustlers university
affiliate program shut down following
metaban
this guy got so big so quick yeah they
put a stop to that
yeah and again i don't know much about
him so i mean it's very possible that
he's not a good guy but there's a lot of
people that aren't a good guy right
it's also possible he's misunderstood or
whatever and you know i don't i don't
care you know whether people are good or
bad to me is such a boring and
it's like
it's like what is the greater what is
the what is the greater
threat
this guy
or companies deciding whether or not you
can speak
it's like
is this a guy
this like
pickup artist guy with the university
the biggest threat is he a bigger threat
than
the collusion of government and big tech
this big blob of power that's completely
unaccountable that can
shut you off at any time is that
not dangerous at all does that not merit
a discussion
and we're talking about a rom whether a
romanian guy got in a fight with his
girlfriend in 2017
because he's got he's hot on the
internet for three months
this is this is the thing
he must be vanquished now
before what he becomes the president
i'm i'm confused
as always
again
it's not defending you know
the the the forest for the trees which
is something that no one can see and
people choose not to
um
if fathers
cannot
cannot go back to talking to their sons
we're all doomed
doesn't matter if it's entertained or
whoever
if if people cannot
go back to educating their children
about how to act and behave
then i i don't know what hope there is
really
so this guy can be as kind of a
scapegoat and he's got some wacky ideas
but
at the end of the day
you know
i think it you know
you gotta look at really
what is the reason
for his popularity
what is the reason for the popularity of
a lot of people
is it because we do live in a world
where many manifestations of traditional
masculinity are kind of bemoaned and
demonized and called toxic
and that
dudes are trying to figure out and
navigate
a new landscape
and sometimes it just feels good if
somebody goes hey [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna say
egregious crazy [ __ ]
because
the new world
is exhausting
tiring
and there's nothing in it for you
they're building a world
where
if you're a straight white guy or any
straight guy really
um
you're constantly told that you
inherently
your nature
is a
danger and a problem
and
there's somebody who comes along and
goes no it's not you're actually fine
you're okay and
that's popular well of course it's going
to be pop why wouldn't it be popular
now yes does it go too far and does he
say crazy [ __ ] i'm sure it's the
internet
but well why is it why is it getting an
audience why is it
gaining traction because no one is
speaking to these young kids young men
young dudes they're
they're not being
served by anybody
speaking to them
groups of people that
are being championed
or being included in a discussion or
being praised
do not include a lot of these young
dudes
who have no idea
where they fit into society
so
it's the job of their fathers are the
job of their families communities but
maybe all that shit's not working right
maybe it's not happening
enter andrew tate enter whoever
and
you know some of what he said i think
that i've heard has been pretty good i
said stop whining figured
figure yourself
out there are ways that you can
be self-reliant
productive
you know this doesn't mean that these
are all
gonna work
but i do think some of it is positive
for sure
um and i've always had a problem when
everybody goes yeah we're just going to
delete
people and then everyone goes good and
then they
enjoy the deplatforming of their enemies
and then when it happens to them they
don't uh
they don't make the connection
they feel
they fail to make the
connection
yeah
but i don't know i would not
i don't know if i'd be buying his course
i don't really i don't know how many
people's course i would buy
what is his course at hustler's universe
is it like lesson one
how to choke a [ __ ] out with a machete
i don't know
it's supposed to be like uh helps you
with investing i'll but i'll join it if
it's about the machete